[Musik]
mein kino tipp für lange corona abende
barry lyndon von stanley kubrick
das ist wahrscheinlich der opulente sste
der waghalsigsten der außergewöhnlichste
versuch der filmgeschichte das leben von
menschen in bildern einzufassen 185
minuten pure sinnliche schönheit kostüme
ausstattung die art der kamera sowie das
hier eingefangen wird er hat man es
vorher und nachher nie wieder gesehen
koubek hat daran sehr sehr lange gedreht
und das ist wahrscheinlich der
meisterhafte film von ihm und meistens
hat man nicht genug zeit um diesen film
auf sich wirken zu lassen das hat man
jetzt und zusammen mit dieser
ausserordentlichen reichen sinnlichen
vorstellungen die man hier bekommt es
ist eigentlich der einzige film der uns
in dieser schwierigen einsamen stunden
helfen kann
deutsche komödien sind normalerweise
echt ein problem sind fürchterliche
drehbücher menschen sagen sätze die sie
niemals sagen würden und deswegen sind
die komödien von jan georg schütte
suchen kann ich kein drehbuch
jetzt zum beispiel im sommer wollen oder
stellt einfach leute zusammen meistens
sehr gute schauspieler und lässt sich
einfach machen und da gibt es momentan
schon mehrere unter anderem den sehr
sehr schönen film wellness trip haare
mit anke engelke mit einem mädel mit
stresow eine wirklich gute schauspieler
und die spielen paare die in einen
wellness schlösschen ankommen sich so
klassisches verwöhnwochenende können das
ganze hat aber unangenehmer weise auch
noch eine therapie anteil und wie diese
paare da sich menschen durch schiffen
und das ganze ertragen oder auch nicht
ertragen ist sehr sehr lustig
anzuschauen und etwas was man im
deutschen fernsehen wirklich nur ganz
selten sind mich wirklich lustige
dialoge eternal sunshine of the spotless
mind ist ein absolut magischer film für
viele kritiker einer der bands
filme des frühen 21 jahrhunderts gesagt
geht es darum dass jim carrey mit kate
winslet so ein bisschen pech in der
liebe hatte und sie jetzt aus seinem
gedächtnis löschen lassen will
was tatsächlich geht es gibt da so eine
firma die kommen zu dir nach hause
bringen risiken mit denen sie die auf
den kopf setzen und zapfen dein gehirn
an während du schliefst und löschen
deine erinnerungen und während dieses
prozesses wie sollte es auch anders sein
denkt sich jim carrey dass er so manche
erinnerung an kennt menzel die bei doch
behalten will
wir sind als zuschauer in jim carreys
kopf dabei was wirklich so real und
inszeniert ist ich will nicht zu viel
verraten von der handlung aber so von
den details hier stimmt einfach alles
von den alexander profit hatten bis zu
kate winslets wechselnden haben die den
aktuellen zustand der nation
widerspiegeln also sehr tiefgründig sehr
melancholisch sehr sehenswert und wer
den film gesehen hat und danach nicht
durch die wohnung läuft in soundtrack
mitzogen
er hat meiner meinung nach kein herz
allen die ihn in diesen tagen noch nicht
gesehen haben möchte ich konnten
empfehlen von steven soderberghs film
von 2011 hochaktuell und sehr rasant
passt sich der geschwindigkeit des virus
an um das es geht und dass ich das kommt
dann irgendwie bekannt vor über
oberflächen ausbreitet und einen
beträchtlichen anteil der protagonisten
zu denen auch so bekannte leute wie matt
damon und gwyneth paltrow gehören
dahinrafft
das mag jetzt etwas makaber klingen ich
finde dennoch dass man diesen film in
diesen tagen sehen sollte
nicht nur weil er so experimentell
gemacht ist sondern eben auch weil er
uns bewusst macht wie gut es ist dass
wir mit einem virus zu tun haben das
nicht ganz so tödlich ist wie groß die
gefahr ist die von verschwörungstheorien
und fehlinformationen ausgeht der welt
kursieren in solchen fällen
und weil wir im anschluss danach
vielleicht nicht gleich an die nächste
türklinke greifen
das hat er durchaus auch seinen vorteil
nach meiner zeit bei der bundeswehr habe
ich mich entschlossen das weit entfernte
neuseeland zu reisen aber auch nach über
einem jahr konnte ich dieses
wunderschöne land nicht richtig
verstehen
bis sich dann den film award 2010 im
kino gesehen habe
dann geht es um den kleinen jungen
genannt bei dem verschlafenen nest auf
der nordinsel lebt und sich vor der
tristesse des verlassenen dorfes
flüchtet in eine wunderschöne und
witzige fantasiewelt vor allem aber
fehlt boy eine vaterfigur
denn sein leiblicher vater sitzt gehört
als kleinkrimineller eine
gefängnisstrafe ab und das führt
natürlich zu ganz vielen täuschen denn
wie sie bei sein vater vorstellung ist
superhelden das erweist sich in der
realität dann als gänzlich falsch
der film bietet viel tragischer bock
viel komik wer also die verschrobene
kleine dorf welt neuseelands besser
verstehen will der sollte sich unbedingt
anschauen
ich empfehle der pate von francis ford
coppola aus dem jahr 1970 oscar prämiert
dreht sich um eine mafia familie im new
york der 70er jahre die in territorial
kämpfe verstrickt ist eigentlich geht es
aber um den jüngsten sohn der familie
michael corleone ganz großartig gespielt
von apple kino der ursprünglich
aussteigen wollte aus diesem ganzen
klaren strukturen aber am ende doch
hineingezogen wird und sehr sehr
schwerwiegende entscheidungen treffen
muss warum es das ganze systems wird
coppola hat nicht nur großartig diesen
filmen fotografieren lassen mit ganz
tollen kamera arbeiten
er hat auch sich sehr viel zeit dafür
genommen sich anzuschauen wie
funktioniert familienstrukturen wie
funktionieren machtstrukturen und wie
agieren menschen darin charaktere sind
ganz hervorragend ausgearbeitet sind
ganz tolle schauspieler dabei und
sämtliche popkulturellen referenzen der
letzten 50 jahre beziehen sich auf
diesen film
obendrein gibt es zwei tolle
fortsetzungen karte zwei und drei beide
um zwischen 200 und 100 60 minuten lang
also man hat sehr sehr lange zeit die
man sich gut vertreiben kann mit diesem
film
die filmtrilogie millennium kann ich
auch sehr empfehlen wie der name schon
sagt drei teile also auch super wieder
für den 2
was ich sehr gut fand ist dass viele
tabu themen angesprochen werden
teilweise korruption teilweise
verschwörung und auch vergewaltigungen
ist super grafisch umgesetzt
deswegen würde ich sagen nichts für
schwache nerven
ja ich will gar nicht viel vorwegnehmen
ist eine schwedische filmreihe und ein
teil ist besser als der andere
also lohnt sich auf jeden fall der
sichtlichen zeit eine situation nach
trash nach schießereien nach action
sehen
dem würde ich den film red heat
empfehlen in den hauptrollen spielen an
als schwarzenegger ein politischer kopf
und jim belushi sign amerikanischen kopf
in das geht einfach so dass ein
georgischer mafiosi von anderen
schwarzenegger gejagt wird der sich aber
also der sich hier heute schon mal klose
in den usa absetzt von jim belushi
gefangen wird und dann an als
schwarzenegger gerufen wird um zurück in
unsere betten zu bringen dabei geht er
mal was gehörig schief
die beiden müssen dann diesen gordischen
mafiosi in den straßen von new york
jagen absoluter trash film über
freundschaft die über grenzen hinaus
leicht an die sowjets die orangen und
stress
mag
[Musik]